hello, how are you, hector mejía greets you with
his brief informative report today is friday
may 28 the board of directors of
conventions on vice day and says that
around two and a half million
people visited the city of las
vegas last month this represents an
increase of  15 percent since March
, however, it is below 27
percent if we compare it with the numbers
registered in April 2019
and the casinos in Nevada are generating
more profits the properties earned an
approximate of 1 billion last month
however the board
nevada gaming control says the state wo
n't be able to recover until
international flights are reintroduced they
forecast this to happen maybe the
first two months of 2022
and if you're looking for a place to relax this
holiday weekend you should
consider going to manchester and  which offers
various entertainment games
parking is free but on a
first come first served basis this viewer will open on
friday  Monday to Sunday
now we go to the weather forecast
we will have temperatures in the high
90s for today Friday almost close
to 100 degrees so have
sun protection handy then
some clouds for tomorrow Saturday and
warmer temperatures for Monday
'memorial day' have a nice day I am
héctor mejía and this was your brief
informative of x day in Spanish
[Music]